welcome to this blitz game against hoax
hoax d me hago con ok so what am I doing
here I can maybe maybe what about the
stone Moya cards and used it to beat
vishy anand nicely i can try that as
well let's see yeah this c6 first is
some designed to provoke right and
playing him an early am Knight f3 he
didn't do that hmm ok I thought he might
try to get into him night h3 set up with
b3 first ok yeah this Bishop f4 is a
typical way to play it is a very solid
way for white of course to play one
thing is he has played b 3 which
prevents queen bee three from from ever
be possible and this way I get in this
this night this Bishop maneuver
sometimes y can play an early queen bee
three to attack the beep on so that
Bishop d7 is not even possible in this
Sun in this type of 0 is closing it down
completely haha
okay let's put it to put it here first
yeah this is a obviously very close
position Wow f3
okay this is a case where you can argue
who's got the worst Bishop White's
bishop on g2 isn't exactly great great
item ok so g 5y am this is this is the
key move anyway good to open it up and
he has a case where he cannot even play
III due to the pin on the pawn so 1 i'm
probably a bit quicker now with with the
g file opening okay so he allows me to
take on a form interesting
yeah i can check okay not clear there
are this what what is best yeah I mean
it's not clear to me I okay this was as
IBM and then trying to to do what
exactly 22 F for maybe but I'm really
quickly on the G file with the rocks
here let's say let's think up for a
moment here how do i do that this rule
of g8 is a very obvious move but applic
him it's probably probably is the best
move here and now this is an interesting
moment what about this position here if
he takes on g4 i can take with the pawn
it makes some sense if you place h3 i
can take its not leading to much really
isn't my night on this seven is not
doing anything
how can I have a team he maybe has he
maybe has some queen of six Cham really
not that much going on yeah I don't see
another don't see another route for the
night really he's taking them why that I
didn't expect I can take with the pawn
now always amazed at those important
decision taken basically instantly but
okay mostly they get away with it yeah
like putting your night on the edge of
the board Jeff with got almost no
squares on but ok so g3 I skeptic the
check is not leading to much cheese
fries got rook f1 of course yeah so
cruelly this one I don't know yeah he
could tip it was okay taking on before
it doesn't lose instantly or anything so
he could play it
okay so if i take now on edge for years
God rukia fadem jump down to one minute
where did I spend all that time Young a
question that I'm them used to okay no
my rook is hanging that's not nice what
I'm didn't really think about that at
all that malukas no square now ha
ridiculous is that ok snow squid black
resigns yeah that was bad I went from a
pretty good position to do to losing in
a couple of moves but yeah rook takes
chief is a surprising move for me I mean
look so do something strange for me but
ok putting the night on the edge and
everything looks looks weird but how
should I play that ok this is this is
clear and I should just play group Queen
g7 right winter so now I have I didn't
really I didn't really think a thing go
firm of the rook f6 tactics so if i take
now look here
this is he is moving that yeah this is
what i need to do I mean he's got got
got this is a silly night on h4 so I
cannot really be worse iam maybe I k can
play maybe III 92 to have form this is
what I need to do maybe it's about equal
i don't know i mean this this this is
already bad yeah I don't really have a
move yet look we have six is trapping
murukku I didn't see that I simply
didn't see the idea it's a stupid am I
only thought okay rook e8 is the problem
but who cares sixes of course happening
I have to take now where this is already
a bit this is a bit strange whenever
this is silly not on edge for gets
traded I mean this is this is this a bit
weird yeah I don't really know okay
maybe I can somehow get in King g8 he's
got the open hi this is sister this is a
bad position I really have to play this
this stuff check I was still wonder the
computer wants to take with the rook but
what is wrong with taking with the King
I don't see it this also should be quite
okay and is this this this is certainly
okay for luck I don't don't believe in
this for white for an advantage I mean
yeah this is a certainty okay this is
okay I mean why test this is double
ponent and TI ya this is um he's moving
as well yeah it's not anything yeah here
I have night f-86 I'm covering those two
squares I think it should be may be
about equal yeah okay i blundered this
rook f6 idea didn't see it at all okay
well thanks for watching